[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL JACKSON: These
ethical concerns
don't come about because
of simple binary choices
between being good or evil.
They come about largely
because of lack of awareness.
SARAH HANSEN: Today
on Chalk Radio,
we're talking about how the
ethical decisions of engineers
shape the software
we use every day.
SERENA BOOTH:
Ultimately, through going
through this concrete
process, the goal
is to get you to identify what
we call value-laden decision
points in your engineering
work and to choose better, just
through being more
informed and deliberate.
SARAH HANSEN: I'm your
host, Sarah Hansen.
This week, we're in conversation
with two MIT scientists
who are thinking deeply about
how software design impacts
our experiences in the world.
They're also
encouraging students
to examine the fault lines
between humans and technology
and helping students to
consider the social and ethical
responsibilities of computing.
My guests are Daniel
Jackson and Serena Booth.
DANIEL JACKSON: I'm a
Professor of Computer Science,
and I'm also an Associate
Director of CSAIL, the Computer
Science and AI Lab at MIT.
SERENA BOOTH: I'm entering my
fourth year as a PhD student
here at MIT.
SARAH HANSEN: Before
collaborating in the classroom,
Daniel and Serena were
both conducting research
at the intersection
of complex technology
and everyday human experiences.
DANIEL JACKSON: The focus of
my work in the last few years
has been to try and
understand design of software
not from the point of view of
its internal structure, which
by the way, is what people
actually mean when they
talk about designing software.
They mean, how do
you write the code,
how do you organize
the code, how do you
fit things together, and so on.
But rather, design in the
sense that anyone out there
in the world would use
the term, namely design
at the interface between
machine and human being.
And I've become very
interested in the question of,
essentially, whether
we can come up
with a kind of grand
theory of design
that can explain how
to design software
so that it's more usable, more
secure, more safe, and more
pleasant.
SERENA BOOTH: I
really want to create
useful general-purpose robots
which collaborate with people.
So it's important to me that
robots don't replace people,
they accentuate the things
that we like in our lives
and take away some of the
chores and the boring things.
I think we often forget
about the need for the person
to work and collaborate
with that robot.
That's where I'm
really interested,
trying to get humans to
understand how robots work
to be able to predict what
they'll do next so that you can
make this collaboration safe and
useful to both human and robot.
SARAH HANSEN: As they've
pursued their own research,
they've both witnessed how
different kinds of seemingly
simple design decisions have
serious social and ethical
implications.
DANIEL JACKSON:
I would say I can
put them very crudely into
three different categories.
The first is that it's very
easy to design and build
a device or a system
or an application that
simply doesn't fulfill
its intended purpose well.
A really compelling
example of this,
for me, is the panoply of
medical devices often designed
by companies that
have great technology
but don't have sufficient
expertise in software
and human-computer
interaction design
to think about questions related
to what kinds of mistakes
the users can make.
So there are many horrendous
stories of infusion pumps,
for example, in which nurses
enter incorrect dosage rates,
and people are killed
or severely injured
because, for example, a
chemotherapy drug is delivered
at much too high a concentration
or much too high a volume.
But medical devices
are just one category
of systems that are often poorly
implemented in a way that,
essentially, doesn't
appreciate how important it
is to accommodate the kinds
of errors that users make.
And I should say, there's also a
well known and very unfortunate
tendency in society to blame
users for the errors they make.
As just one example,
a horrendous accident,
a series of accidents, due to a
radiotherapy machine in Panama
led to all the nurses involved
in it being prosecuted
and, I think, some of
them going to jail,
despite the fact that it was
clearly a system design flaw.
So that's the first
category, things not meeting
their purposes.
The second category is
that they are designed
to meet certain purposes,
but those purposes
are insidious ones.
I'll give you an example of
one which is insidious only
in a mild way, and that is
that a lot of applications
provide some kind of
notification feature.
And you might imagine that's to
serve what the word suggests,
to notify the users.
So Facebook tells you, for
example, when there might
be posts of interest to you.
But if you dig a
little deeper, and you
look into the question of
how easily you can actually
configure those settings
and decide what you want
to be notified about, you'll
discover that, in fact, you
have very little control.
And what that reveals
is that the real purpose
of this notification
concept is, in fact,
to encourage
engagement in the site
and to draw people to visit
more frequently than is actually
good for them.
That's the second category.
The third category are
basically the respects
in which designs can contribute
to a computational environment
that has subtly
pernicious effects.
And those effects
include, for example,
marginalizing certain
groups of people,
advantaging some
users over others,
encouraging antisocial or
undemocratic behaviors,
creating damage to community,
or even just personally reducing
quality of life by making us
less reflective or creative
or independent by enslaving
us to our devices,
by sapping our attention,
and all these things
that we've all become very
concerned with with the devices
we use but which
are not necessarily
inherent in those devices
but exacerbated by the design
decisions we make.
SERENA BOOTH: I can give
you an anecdote from my days
at Google.
So I'd just graduated
from college.
I was, like, 22 years old.
I'd been at Google
for a few weeks,
and I was working on Search.
And my team came to me, and
we were having this crisis.
We were redesigning the
dinosaurs search page.
And everyone wasn't sure.
We'd gotten a lot of bugs
from parents complaining
about our dinosaurs search page
because "pterodactyl" didn't
appear there, and their
children wanted it there.
And so we had this
little crisis as a team.
We're like, should we put
"pterodactyl" on there?
It's not really a dinosaur.
It's technically
a pterosaur, so we
would be lying to the children.
And because I was
a product manager,
they were like, OK,
Serena, you decide.
And so I just made a decision,
and then we moved on.
And this is like totally
unimportant, right?
It doesn't really
matter if the kids think
pterodactyl is a dinosaur.
But it just opens the
door, the floodgates,
to thinking about how much
control we have over how people
understand the world.
And so, yeah, those
sorts of decisions
are things I think about a lot.
SARAH HANSEN: Serena
and Daniel noticed
a gap between the questions
they were asking themselves
as researchers and what
students were being
asked inside the classroom.
DANIEL JACKSON: I'd
always been troubled
by the way in which
we had perhaps
not only allowed
but even encouraged
our students to marginalize
ethical concerns
and sometimes think of
them in rather trite terms.
One thing that always comes
to mind to me is that, when.
Google was founded, there was
this slogan, "Do no evil."
And there was this sense, I
think, amongst our students
and amongst a lot of
young technologists
that we're good people.
And so it's understandable
that we thought
we didn't want to do evil.
But the truth is, most
people don't want to do evil.
The people in charge
of the companies that
do some of the most terrible
things to the planet
are really not evil people.
Most of them are people who love
their families and friends, who
want to do good in the world.
And these ethical
concerns don't come about
because of simple binary choices
between being good or evil.
They come about largely
because of lack of awareness.
And as we've seen with
Google, for example,
money corrupts everything.
And once you start to be
hugely financially successful,
unless you have a very
strong ethical lens,
it's very hard to resist
the temptations of money.
And I thought it
was very important
for us to be able to inoculate
our students against some
of those temptations
and for them
to develop the kind
of sophistication
in their social and ethical
understanding of the world
that they have in their
technological understanding.
I will say, also, there was a
very simple pragmatic reason
that I wanted to be
involved with SERC,
which was that I didn't
know how to do this myself.
SARAH HANSEN: You may
remember the acronym SERC
from our previous episode with
Catherine D'Ignazio, Jacob
Andreas, and Harini Suresh.
It stands for Social and Ethical
Responsibilities of Computing.
SERENA BOOTH: So recently,
MIT announced its launch
of the College of Computing,
which is a new endeavor
to try to bring
cross-disciplinary computing
all together.
It's going to really
change MIT as we know it.
But as part of that, also,
they've launched SERC.
The goal is to bring all of
the different perspectives
on social and ethical
responsibilities together--
so philosophers,
social scientists,
cognitive scientists, computer
scientists, many more--
and get that coalition of people
to help embed ethics education
into MIT's curriculum,
very broadly.
SARAH HANSEN: In
collaboration with SERC,
Serena joined Daniel as a
graduate teaching assistant
for the course 6.170
Software Studio.
One of their primary
goals was to bring
social and ethical
considerations
into the engineering classroom.
That's when they turned to a
powerful tool called the Ethics
Protocol.
SERENA BOOTH: The
Ethics Protocol
was developed here at MIT.
It was developed by
Milo Phillips-Brown,
who's now an assistant
professor at Oxford University.
And Abby Jaques.
They are both
philosophers by training,
and as they matured
in their careers,
they started to
get more involved
in designing ethics-related
materials for computing,
specifically.
So the Ethics Protocol
is a tool which
tries to assist in
their mission, which
is to teach ethics as a skill.
Ultimately, through going
through this concrete process,
the goal is to get
you to identify
what we call
value-laden decision
points in your engineering
work and to choose better
just through being more
informed and deliberate.
SARAH HANSEN: Daniel
and Serena noted
that it's not possible or
ethical to simply give students
a singular ethical principle
to guide their decision making.
Instead students are introduced
to a set of three lenses
that they can apply when
assessing a project or idea.
The three lenses of
the Ethics Protocol
are outcomes,
structure, and process.
SERENA BOOTH: The
outcomes lens asks
you to analyze the consequences
of a decision or intervention,
and that's a very
intuitive one to use.
The process lens asks you
to consider the treatment
of your stakeholders.
So you should think about
things like your stakeholders'
autonomy, their consent,
their participation.
And then that last lens,
the structure lens,
asks you to analyze how outcomes
and process is distributed
among the stakeholders.
Another good and perhaps more
descriptive name for this lens
would be a justice lens.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So in software
design, we typically
have one definition for
stakeholders, somebody
who's involved in
making, using, or would
be likely to use your software.
You're building for a
relatively small set of people,
and you're trying to be
very mindful of their needs
as you build.
But when you think instead
about ethical implications,
scoping your
stakeholders this way
is just not reasonable, right?
You should also consider
all of the stakeholders who
are affected or could be
affected by your software.
As a concrete
example, perhaps we
could think about a
company like Uber or Lyft.
So under the software
definition of stakeholders,
you probably think about
drivers and customers, right?
Those are the only two
stakeholders who really matter.
But under the Ethics Protocol
definition of stakeholders,
you should think
about others, too.
So the very obvious example
here is traditional taxi drivers
who are being undercut
by these apps.
It's impossible for
you to think of like
every possible stakeholder
and every potential effect
that your software could have.
It's just not tenable, right?
And so there are things that
will be out of your control,
and you have to be OK with that.
But nonetheless,
you should still
try to anticipate as
much as possible to avoid
those unintended
consequences downstream.
SARAH HANSEN: I was
curious what this all
looks like in the
classroom, when
students begin to put the
Ethics Protocol into practice.
DANIEL JACKSON:
Our course consists
of, essentially, two parts.
In the first part
of the term, they're
learning the basic design ideas
and the basic technologies
and putting them together
and applying them
on small,
well-contained problems.
And then in the second
half of the term,
they join together
in teams, and they
take on a larger project
of their own invention.
And they build that
project from concept
to implementation and
deployment and everything.
We introduce these social and
ethical concerns incrementally.
We start with the
individual assignments
by asking them to reflect
on the ethical and social
ramifications of the
assignment they're doing
and the implications
of that assignment.
And we slowly ramp
up the intensity
and the sophistication of the
analysis that we ask from them.
And then, as we move
towards the final project
we ask them to begin to take
those decisions into account
in their own design work.
And then in the
final project, we
encourage them to
develop their ideas
using these lenses
that Serena described
and in the context of
this kind of analysis.
SERENA BOOTH: And it was part
of their deliverable, which
I think is really important.
So it wasn't just
them talking about it.
It was part of their grade.
And it felt very
real and important.
And I think we saw the students
really participate and start
to integrate this into
their thinking, partially
as a consequence of
that integration.
DANIEL JACKSON: It was
actually a surprise even to me,
despite my enthusiasm for
this material, that we found
that there were so many social
and ethical concerns even
in the relatively narrow
context of the rather technical
assignments at the beginning.
So I'll just give
you one example.
We have them build
what we call Fritter.
Fritter is, essentially,
a Twitter clone.
But just questions
regarding, for example,
what kinds of posts are
shown, what the criteria are
for displaying posts, tweets,
or freets, as we call them,
what order they
appear in, and so on
can have social ramifications.
SARAH HANSEN: At this
point in the conversation,
I started wondering what
it was like to teach ethics
in the context of
cancel culture.
But as Daniel and
Serena explained,
students aren't being
taught what to think.
They aren't being asked to
espouse particular ideologies
in the classroom.
Instead, they're learning
how to ask better questions.
SERENA BOOTH: We try
not to be prescriptive.
Sometimes that
can be quite hard,
because we all have
quite a strong sense
of right and wrong.
But instead, what we're
trying to do mostly
is to get the students
to question the decisions
that they're making and to
try to refine and iterate
on their own moral
and ethical compasses.
And so we want them to
develop that understanding
for themselves
through their own lens
and leave MIT with
that knowledge.
DANIEL JACKSON: Just because
something is subjective,
just because we might not
all agree on evaluation
of particular
ethical consequences
doesn't mean that
we can't attain
some kind of objective
understanding of what it means
to have a competent ethical
analysis that is appropriately
far-reaching, balanced, and
deepened in different respects.
One of the things that we're
trying to teach the students
is that this isn't about any
particular ideology or dogma.
As Serena explained, what we do
is we really give them tools.
And we provide them
with these lenses.
And we never suggest that
any one ethical evaluation
is correct and another
one is incorrect.
We don't say that Uber should
make its decisions according
to the impact on the livelihood
of existing taxi drivers.
Nor do we say that the
shareholders of Uber
are the most important
stakeholders.
Nor do we say that the
drivers or the passengers
are important.
The point is that
any design decision
must be made with a
full awareness of which
stakeholders you're actually
taking into account.
And then how you actually
do that yourself,
well, that's of course,
tremendously important.
We're not for a minute
suggesting to the students
that there's any kind of
predefined ethical judgments
that we expect them to make.
And on the contrary,
I think, we'd
actually like to complicate
their understanding.
My goal is always to
persuade the students
and myself the
preconceptions that we
come in with are
too simple-minded
and that there's a lot of work
to be done to understand things
more deeply.
SARAH HANSEN: As they develop
these deeper understandings,
students in Daniel and
Serena's Software Studio course
are also challenging stereotypes
about the kind of work
engineering students
can be passionate about.
DANIEL JACKSON: Our
students, it turns out,
are absolutely passionate about
making their mark in the world
and about being part
of a larger community.
I think it's just a question
of giving them the opportunity
to do this.
I suspect if you
asked them, "Would you
like to take a course on social
and ethical ramifications
of computing?" they
might not list it.
It's actually very much
parallel to the experience
of the humanities at MIT, where
students generally don't rush
towards the humanities classes.
They're required to take some as
part of their General Institute
Requirements.
But when they take
those classes,
typically they love them.
And they love them not
only because they're
a break from the much more
sometimes concrete and narrow
thinking that they do in
their technical classes,
but I think because
it allows them
to bring their whole
selves to their work.
And it makes them feel
that they have agency
and that they are
actually contributing
in a broader and deeper way.
SARAH HANSEN: It isn't
just the students
who are being prompted to think
more deeply and creatively
about engineering coursework.
SERENA BOOTH: So I think
one of the challenges
in embedding SERC materials is
that the university experience
is like very much a bubble.
Normally, you're working
on kind of toy problems.
You're not shipping
software, right?
Your decisions
kind of don't have
social and ethical implications,
because probably your software
isn't going to leave
your hands, really.
Your TA will see it.
Your professor will see it.
But it's still
very closely held.
So something that
I struggle with
is trying to bridge this
gap to having the decisions
that you make have real
world consequences.
And so in this class,
the way we tried
to approach it was by
making it realistic.
But it's still, to some extent,
like building in a sandbox.
And so I'm curious about
what other educators do
to try to make this extremely
real to your students, right?
How can we make the social
and ethical responsibilities
questions tangible?
DANIEL JACKSON:
The other thing I
would say that, for me,
is a very big challenge is
that we're constantly feeling
overwhelmed by the amount
of technical material
that we need to teach.
And we're finding
ways to reduce that
by preparing the students
better in earlier courses,
by flipping the classroom more.
But I would welcome
any ideas that people
have on how to switch students
out of this mindset, that just
learning the details of the
programming language or the web
platform that they're using or
whatever is all that matters
and to get them to
see beyond that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: If
you have insights
to share about teaching social
and ethical responsibilities
of computing, please
get in touch with me
through the link
in our show notes.
I'll pass your ideas
along to Daniel, Serena,
and other listeners.
If you're interested in learning
more about ethics and software
design or remixing
Daniel and Serena's
open educational resources
in your own teaching
head on over to our MIT
OpenCourseWare website.
You'll find all the
materials there.
Thank you so much for listening.
Until next time, signing off
from Cambridge, Massachusetts,
and about to go
google "pterodactyl,"
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Chalk Radio's producers
include myself, Brett Paci,
and Dave Lishansky.
Script writing assistance
from Aubrey Calaway.
Show notes for this episode
were written by Peter Chipman.
And the SERC
resource site on OCW
was built by Cathleen Nalyzaty.
We're funded by MIT Open
Learning and supporters
like you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]